Welcome back!
-What is up?!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm very happy.
-You're very happy.
-Yes.
I want to be happy tonight.
We flipped the damn House!
-There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on!
-Way to go.
It's a big deal.
-It is a big deal.
-And the last time
you were here,
we talked about this initiative
you started
called Glam up the Midterms.
You took this very seriously,
and you invested
a lot of personal time.
-You're not gonna ask me
about a bowl of popcorn
that I'm holding?
-Why do you have
a bowl of popcorn?
-I brought it from
your dressing room because...
now that we flipped the House,
Maxine Waters is now head
of the House Financial --
What is that called?
-Yeah, the --
-The Financial Committee,
which means she can ask
for Donald Trump's taxes,
and I'm just gonna sit back
and watch.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
-Yeah.
That is pro--
I would guess that would be
Donald Trump's least --
That would be his last choice
for who would be in charge
of that committee.
-Yeah.
He doesn't like her.
-No.
-Because he's a racist.
-Oh, yeah.
That's one of the reasons.
That's definitely
one of the reasons.
-Oh, oh!
And a misogynist. Sorry.
-Oh, yeah, that's right.
She ticks a lot of boxes.
-Ticks a lot of boxes, yeah.
No, I'm so excited.
And I did start this
Glam up the Midterms campaign.
I was out there
registering young voters,
trying to get them involved,
and I got so many messages
today on social media
all day long,
on Instagram, on Twitter,
all these young people
all over the country,
sending me photos of going to
vote for the first time,
going to vote in a midterm
for the first time
gathering with
groups of friends,
and I was really moved.
And I'm not the cause
of any of that.
I just think
that they are responding
to things
they're seeing in our country
that they don't feel
are right and just and fair.
And I want to thank all
the young people out there
who got involved
for the first time.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I think
they're gonna stay involved,
and I'm seeing a lot of sadness
tonight on social media
from young people
who really fell in love,
rightfully so, with Beto.
-Mm-hmm.
-And I love him, too,
but I want everyone to realize
that no Democrat has ever gotten
that close in Texas.
-Yeah.
-It's Texas!
[ Cheers and applause ]
You know?
And Beto's not going anywhere.
And we had a really great night,
and I think, you know,
when Republicans win, they go
celebrating in the streets
like, racists start
throwing parades for themselves,
and we're punishing ourselves.
But we had a really great night,
so let's be happy
for five minutes.
-There you go -- five minutes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean, I do think one of the
sad things is, like you said,
a very charismatic candidate
like Beto O'Rourke
doesn't break through
against Ted Cruz.
Do you think,
with what you saw from him --
and a lot of people
are talking about this now --
should he run for president
in two years?
Is he a national candidate?
-I think he is.
I'm gonna leave it up to him
to decide, probably.
[ Laughter ]
But I love --
I want him to win everything.
I want him to win
Best Supporting Actress.
I mean, like, I love the man.
-Yeah.
-Who doesn't?
He's magical.
You know, I think a lot of us
haven't felt that way
about a politician since Obama,
and I think
Beto's gonna be great.
Give the man a second,
and I'll follow him
wherever he wants to go, and I
think a lot of us feel that way.
But tonight, beyond Beto -- and
this is what I want to stress --
was a great night.
We had a Native American
gay woman
flip a seat blue in Kansas.
-Kansas!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-In Kansas!
That's -- That's amazing.
Sharice Davids.
And she's awesome.
It's the gayest thing
to happen in Kansas
since a house fell on the
Wicked Witch of the West.
[ Laughter ]
I mean -- Oh!
You guys don't know this maybe
'cause you've been here,
but voters in Michigan tonight
voted to legalize marijuana!
-That's fantastic.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And that's the only thing
I know about Michigan.
[ Laughter ]
-You now have one fact.
-I now have on fact.
But it's a good one.
-You also --
You got to spend time
with former Vice President
Joe Biden in Las Vegas.
-Yes, yes.
-How was your time with him?
-It was great.
He didn't know who I was.
-Yeah.
-But that was fine.
He shouldn't.
He's Joe Biden.
And it was great.
It's part of the
Glam up the Midterms campaign.
We went all over.
We went to Phoenix,
we went to Vegas,
we went to Detroit,
went to San Diego
before the California primaries.
I went canvassing.
We did what we could.
We went to Arizona.
I don't know yet if we know
what happened,
but Arizona has a great
Democratic candidate
running for Senate tonight,
Kyrsten Sinema,
and we're still waiting
to find out what happens,
but she would be the first
bisexual woman --
openly bisexual woman --
in Congress ever.
And not only that,
but she would be
the first "Kirsten"
in the Senate
who spells her name with a Y.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
And, listen, think about
how much hope that would give
all the horrible
Karens out there
who spell their name
K-A-R-Y-N.
Or all the awful Ashleys
who spell their name
A-S-H-L-E-I-G-H.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, that's terrible.
-Yeah.
She would give them hope.
-Give them some inspiration.
-Yeah.
So I think it's pretty close
in Arizona right now
so hopefully she pulls through.
-Did you vote today,
or did you vote early?
-No, I voted early, yeah.
I voted with an absentee ballot,
and then I sent it in.
-And do you get a sticker
when you do that?
-I do get a sticker, yeah.
-Gotcha.
-They give you a little sticker.
-In the ballot
when they send it to you?
-No, Seth, that comes as
a special FedEx delivery.
No, yeah.
It comes in the same envelope.
-'Cause that seems expensive
if they would FedEx everybody.
-People love
those stupid stickers.
-They love their stickers.
-Social media was crazy today.
-Yeah.
People were really happy.
-What about pizza to the polls?
Have you guys heard about this?
-No.
-Yeah, no, this is real.
Pizza to the polls.
All the people
waiting in line forever
because Republicans have made it
impossible to vote.
So people waiting in line
for hours,
you can go to
PizzaToThePolls.com
or dot org or dot something,
and you can pay to have pizzas
delivered to the people
waiting in line.
I spent $100 to send pizza
to the polls.
Meanwhile, there are members
of my extended family
I haven't spoken to
in seven years.
[ Laughter ]
But there I am --
"Okay, pizza to the polls!
Pizza to the polls!"
-I'm sure they understand
and will forgive you.